We are living in stressful times. Every day, headlines are full of economic uncertainty, political polarization, and global conflict. These are political challenges, but they are also personal. APA's 2025 Stress in America survey found that 62% of U.S. adults reported societal division as a significant source of stress in their lives, while three-quarters said they are more stressed about the country's future than they used to be. Living with this stress can pose real threats to individuals and communities, health and well-being. Today we're going to talk about how societal stress gets under our skin
我们生活在一个充满压力的时代。每天，头条新闻都充斥着经济不确定性、政治极化和全球冲突。这些是政治挑战，但它们也是个人的挑战。美国心理学协会（APA）2025年“美国压力”调查发现，62%的美国成年人表示社会分歧是他们生活中压力的一个重要来源，同时四分之三的人表示，他们对国家未来的压力比过去更大了。带着这种压力生活，会对个人和社区、健康以及幸福感构成真正的威胁。今天我们要讨论的是，社会压力是如何侵入我们的皮肤
to affect our health and mental health. What kinds of ripples are we seeing in communities right now? Who is most vulnerable? And what concrete steps can you take to protect your well-being in these turbulent times? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Today we're joining with our colleagues at the American Public Health Association to bring you a special episode exploring these issues. I'm pleased to welcome to this episode APA CEO Arthur C. Evans Jr. and APHA CEO George's Benjamin.
从而影响我们的健康和心理健康。我们现在在社区中看到了什么样的涟漪？谁最脆弱？在这个动荡的时代，你可以采取哪些具体步骤来保护你的身心健康？欢迎收听“心理学对话”（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。今天，我们与美国公共卫生协会（American Public Health Association）的同仁联合推出一期特别节目，探讨这些问题。很高兴在这期节目中欢迎APA首席执行官阿瑟·C·埃文斯（Arthur C. Evans Jr.）博士和APHA首席执行官乔治·本杰明（George's Benjamin）博士。
Dr. Evans is CEO of the American Psychological Association and a clinical and community psychologist and health care innovator who has employed science, community activism, traditional clinical care, and cross-system collaboration. to change the status quo around behavioral health. Before joining APA in 2017, he spent 12 years as Commissioner of Philadelphia's Department of Behavioral Health and Intellectual Disability Services, where he emphasized the population health approach to serving a wide range of individuals with complex needs.
埃文斯博士是美国心理学协会的首席执行官，也是一名临床与社区心理学家以及医疗保健创新者，他一直致力于运用科学、社区行动主义、传统临床护理以及跨系统协作来改变行为健康的现状。在2017年加入APA之前，他在费城行为健康和智力残疾服务局担任了12年局长，在那里他强调采用人口健康方法来为具有复杂需求的广泛人群服务。
Dr. Evans has also held faculty appointments at Yale University and the University of Pennsylvania's School of Medicine. An outspoken proponent of psychological science and mental health, he has been featured in major media outlets, including the New York Times, the Wall Street Journal, the Washington Post, NBC Nightly News, and ABC News. Dr. George's Benjamin has served as CEO of the American Public Health Association since 2002 and is one of the nation's most influential physician leaders. He joined APHA after serving as Secretary of the Maryland Department of Health and Mental Hygiene, where he oversaw the expansion and improvement. of the state's Medicaid program. Dr. Benjamin is board certified in internal medicine and is a master of of the American College of Physicians, a fellow of the National Academy of Public Administration, a fellow emeritus of the American College of Emergency Physicians, and an honorary fellow
埃文斯博士还曾在耶鲁大学和宾夕法尼亚大学医学院担任教职。作为心理科学和心理健康的直言不讳的倡导者，他曾出现在各大主流媒体上，包括《纽约时报》、《华尔街日报》、《华盛顿邮报》、《NBC晚间新闻》和《ABC新闻》。乔治·本杰明博士自2002年以来一直担任美国公共卫生协会首席执行官，是美国最有影响力的医生领导者之一。在加入APHA之前，他曾担任马里兰州卫生和心理卫生部部长，在那里他监督了该州医疗补助（Medicaid）计划的扩展和改进。本杰明博士是内科医学特许医师，是美国内科医师学会大师级会员、美国公共行政学会院士、美国急诊医师学会荣誉退休院士以及
of the Faculty of Public Health and an honorary fellow of the Royal Society of Public Health. He started his medical career as a military physician in 1978. He is the author of more than 200 scientific articles and book chapters, as well as the book, Public Health Under Siege, Improving Policy in Turbulent Times. Dr. Evans, Dr. Benjamin, thank you for joining me. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology. Thanks, Kim, for having us here. Thank you. Glad to be here. As I mentioned a moment ago, we are living through a period of intense national tension with political polarization, economic anxiety, and other stressors weighing on people's minds. Dr. Benjamin, how does this societal stress affect people's physical health and what kinds of impact
公共卫生学院荣誉院士和英国皇家公共卫生学会荣誉院士。他的医学职业生涯始于1978年的军事医师。他是200多篇科学文章和书籍章节的作者，也是《围困中的公共卫生：在动荡时期改善政策》一书的作者。埃文斯博士，本杰明博士，谢谢你们加入我的节目。欢迎来到“心理学对话”。谢谢金邀请我们来这里。谢谢。很高兴来到这里。正如我刚才提到的，我们正经历一个国家紧张局势加剧的时期，政治极化、经济焦虑和其他压力源压在人们的心头。本杰明博士，这种社会压力如何影响人们的身体健康，它会对我们的身体产生什么样的影响
can it have on our bodies as well as our minds? Well, you know, Kim, public health has long understood the fact of the social determinants of health actually impact your health. I always say that 80% of what makes you healthy occurs outside the doctor's office. And we know that chronic societal stress activates the body stress response. You get elevated cortisol levels, increase inflammation, your sleep gets disrupted. And over time, that would cause increases for cardiovascular disease, diabetes, and ultimately immune dysfunction. If it happens for a long period of time, you get something called allostatic load. And that's where there's cumulative wear and tear in your body from chronic stress is a way for us to think about what happens over time.
以及我们的思维？嗯，你知道，金，公共卫生长期以来一直了解健康社会决定因素实际上会影响你的健康这一事实。我总是说，让你保持健康的80%发生在医生办公室之外。我们知道，长期的社会压力会激活人体的压力反应。你的皮质醇水平升高，炎症加剧，睡眠受到干扰。随着时间的推移，这会导致心血管疾病、糖尿病以及最终免疫功能障碍的风险增加。如果这种情况持续很长时间，你就会得到所谓的“别构负荷”（allostatic load）。这是由慢性压力在你的身体中产生的累积磨损，是我们思考随着时间推移会发生什么的一种方式。
And certainly people are carrying much more stress than it did even a decade ago. So it's not just a mental health issue. It's actually a whole body issue and from a public health perspective, a whole community health issue. And Dr. Evans, what about the impact on people's mental health? Well, as Dr. Benjamin mentioned, stress can have an impact on not only our physical health, but our mental health and our social connections as well. From a mental health standpoint, we can see increased substance use. We can see people might develop an anxiety disorder or depression or any other kind of mental health challenge that they might be susceptible to. And that we can see these play out in people's relationships.
当然，人们承受的压力比十年前甚至还要大得多。所以这不仅仅是一个心理健康问题。它实际上是一个全身体的问题，从公共卫生的角度来看，是一个全社区健康的问题。埃文斯博士，对人们心理健康的影响又如何呢？嗯，正如本杰明博士所提到的，压力不仅会对我们的身体健康产生影响，还会对我们的心理健康和社会联系产生影响。从心理健康的角度来看，我们可以看到物质使用增加。我们可以看到人们可能会患上焦虑症或抑郁症，或他们可能易感的任何其他类别的心理健康挑战。我们可以看到这些在人们的关系中表现出来。
We can see them play out in family relationships. We can see them play out in work relationships. And so the takeaway here is that stress not only affects us from a physical standpoint, but from a mental health standpoint and from a social standpoint. Now, people experience these stressors differently. And there are other factors like housing, instability, food, insecurity, and economic precarity that also shape how people experience and recover from stress. How do these structural conditions interact with the mental health impacts we've been discussing, Dr. Evans? Well, you know, stress, you know, when I was trained, we thought of stress more from an individual standpoint.
我们可以看到它们在家庭关系中表现出来。我们可以看到它们在工作关系中表现出来。因此，这里的核心信息是，压力不仅从身体角度影响我们，还从心理健康和社交角度影响我们。现在，人们对这些压力源的体验各不相同。还有其他因素，如住房不稳定、粮食不安全和经济不稳固，它们也塑造了人们如何体验和从压力中恢复。这些结构性条件如何与我们一直在讨论的心理健康影响相互作用，埃文斯博士？嗯，你知道，压力，你知道，当我接受培训时，我们更多地从个人的角度来思考压力。
And I think over time, we have understood the real impact that stress collectively can have on us and some of the factors that are in our environment that drive the stress that we experience. And one of the things we know is that depending on who you are in our society, you may be experiencing stress differently. We saw, for example, during the pandemic, that parents of young children in particular experience more stress than of other people during the pandemic. And one of the reasons is that younger parents of younger children have more responsibilities than other parents. We know that if you are a farmer, for example, the rate of suicide for farmers is two to three times
我认为随着时间的推移，我们已经理解了压力对我们集体产生的真正影响，以及我们环境中推动我们所经历的压力的某些因素。我们知道的一件事是，根据你在我们社会中的身份，你对压力的体验可能会有所不同。例如，我们在大流行期间看到，特别是幼儿父母在大流行期间比其他人经历了更多的压力。原因之一是年幼孩子的年轻父母比其他父母承担更多的责任。我们知道，如果你是一个农民，例如，农民的自杀率是
that of the general population. And when you dig down into that, what you find is that farmers are experiencing disproportionate economic stress. And in fact, that's one of the things that drives a lot of the psychological distress the farmers experience. So depending on where you are in society, these stressors are not only affecting all of us, but they are affecting some of us disproportionately. And it's really important to understand what are the things that are driving stressors for us as individuals,
普通人口的两到三倍。当你深入研究这一点时，你会发现农民正在经历不成比例的经济压力。事实上，这就是推动农民经历的大量心理困扰的原因之一。因此，根据你在社会中的位置，这些压力源不仅在影响我们所有人，而且它们对我们中的一些人产生了不成比例的影响。非常重要的是要了解是什么在推动我们作为个体的压力源，
but also what are the stressors that are driving us as a group. And Dr. Benjamin, from your vantage point, what are these factors like housing instability and food insecurity and the economy? How are they affecting people's physical health? You know, Kim, I think the big issue here is the fact that people have never really had any rest. When people go into combat and military, we take them out of circulation so they can get we call crew rest. When I used to run the EMS system here in Washington, D.C., we would put our EMS workers and our firefighters giving them some downtime. Well, the population in our country has not had any downtime. For the last 20 years, we've had a pandemic, we've had economic disruptions,
还有什么是作为群体的压力源。本杰明博士，从您的角度来看，住房不稳定、粮食不安全和经济等这些因素是什么？它们是如何影响人们的身体健康的？你知道，金，我认为这里的大问题是人们从未真正有过任何休息。当人们进入战斗和军队时，我们把他们带出流通领域，以便他们能得到我们所说的船员休息（crew rest）。当我过去在华盛顿特区运营EMS系统时，我们会让我们的EMS工人和消防员给他们一些停机时间。嗯，我们国家的人口没有任何停机时间。在过去的20年里，我们经历了一场大流行，我们经历了经济动荡，
at least two of them. We've had social unrest, we have political polarization, and what's happening right now is on steroids. So the fact that you have these recurring events that have not resulted in any ability of the body to reduce the amount of stress, so you have prolonged stress activation that's just tearing people down. So you're seeing more fatigue, more people that are just depressed. We're seeing more suicide, even in kids. And then when you add to that, the social isolation that has occurred partially to the pandemic, but also the fact that people are now engaged in their electronic devices. So they're not interacting with people one-on-one or even groups. We're now seeing things much different in terms of what people are experiencing from a stress
至少两次。我们经历过社会动乱，我们有政治极化，而现在发生的事情就像打了兴奋剂一样。因此，你拥有这些没有导致身体任何减少压力能力大小的重复事件，所以你拥有长期持续的压力激活，这正在摧毁人们。所以你会看到更多的疲劳，更多的人只是感到沮丧。我们看到更多的自杀，甚至在儿童中。然后当你再加上由于部分大流行而发生的部分社会隔离时，但也由于人们现在沉迷于他们的电子设备。所以他们不与人一对一甚至成群互动。我们现在从压力的角度看到人们所经历的事情有着很大的不同
perspective. And that stress response is phenomenally damaging to their health. So for our listeners, what are some actions that they can take to counteract these effects? What are some practical skills or tools that people can use? Let's talk about first how to protect their mental health in these times. Dr. Evans. So I think it really starts with understanding stress, what causes stress, and what are some of the things that can mitigate and reduce stress. So we know that having social support is a big factor in how much stress
这种压力反应对他们的健康具有惊人的破坏性。那么对于我们的听众来说，他们可以采取哪些行动来抵消这些影响？人们可以使用的实用技能或工具是什么？让我们首先讨论如何在这些时期保护他们的心理健康。埃文斯博士。因此，我认为这 realmente 从理解压力、导致压力的原因以及可以减轻和减少压力的某些事情开始。我们知道，拥有社会支持是我们作为人所经历的压力
and how much distress we experience as people. And social support, increasing our relationships is a, a very important thing. But also how we think about stress. One of the things that we know happens with people is that people who catastrophize, that is, they think of the worst possible outcomes of the things that they're experiencing are going to experience more stress, more psychological distress, and then have some of the kinds of mental health and physical health outcomes that we were talking about. And when we work with people, one of the things we do is a technique calls cognitive reframing or restructuring.
和困扰程度的一个重要因素。社会支持，增加我们的关系是一个非常重要的事情。但也是我们如何看待压力。我们知道人们身上发生的一件事情是，灾难化的人，也就是说，他们认为他们正在经历的事情的最坏可能结果，将会经历更多的压力，更多的心理困扰，然后产生我们一直在谈论的某些心理健康和身体健康结果。当我们与人们合作时，我们做的事情之一就是一种叫做认知重构（cognitive reframing）或重组的技术。
That is thinking about our problems differently can go a long way and how we experience those problems. But then there are all these other things that we can do that have to do with our physical health. If we get enough sleep, making sure that we have a good diet, making sure that we exercise, all of those things have a profound impact on how we experience stress and how we're able to manage stress. So it really comes down to if you kind of thought about three domains in our lives, how we think, making sure that we're not only not catastrophizing, but really trying to not only see our problems from a realistic standpoint, but also trying to see solutions and understand things from various perspectives. But then there's a domain of our social life. We know that, as I was mentioning, social support, but the opposite can also drive our stress.
也就是说，对我们的问题有不同的思考方式，对于我们如何体验这些问题大有帮助。但随后还有所有这些我们可以做的与我们的身体健康有关的其他事情。如果我们获得足够的睡眠，确保我们有良好的饮食，确保我们锻炼，所有这些事情都对我们如何体验压力以及我们如何管理压力产生深远的影响。所以这归结为，如果你考虑我们生活中的三个领域：我们如何思考，确保我们不仅不灾难化，而且真正努力不仅从现实的角度看待我们的问题，而且努力看到解决方案并从各种角度理解事物。但随后是我们的社会生活领域。我们知道，正如我所提到的，社会支持，但相反的情况也可能推动我们的压力。
That is loneliness. In fact, the Sergeant General did a report a few years ago on the impact. loneliness and what a negative impact that it can have on both our physical health and our mental health. So making sure that we're doing what we can in that domain as well to ensure that we have the kind of support and then making sure in the physical domain that we're doing the things to stay healthy. That kind of broad-based strategy can really be very effective at helping us to manage our stress and mitigate the impact of stress on our lives. Dr. Benjamin, anything you would add to that? I think
也就是说，孤独。事实上，外科医生总长（Surgeon General）几年前发表了一份关于孤独的影响以及它对我们的身体健康和心理健康产生的负面影响的报告。因此，确保我们在该领域尽我们所能，以确保我们拥有那种支持，然后确保在身体领域我们做保持健康的事情。这种广泛的战略可以非常有效地帮助我们管理压力，减轻压力对我们生活的影响。本杰明博士，你有什么要补充的吗？我认为
Arthur's points are well taken, and I would add to that community engagement. First of all, cutting off your devices, I tell people you need some me time. Every day. Just find some time, even if it's 15 minutes, go into a quiet place, wherever you normally think when someone's getting
阿瑟的观点很有道理，我想补充的是社区参与。首先，切断你的设备，我告诉人们你需要一些“属于我自己的时间”（me time）。每天。只要找点时间，哪怕是15分钟，去一个安静的地方，任何你通常在有人惹恼你时思考的地方，
on your last nerve, cutting on some music, just so that you can just engage so you can think about yourself. But the other thing is, you can help other people, engaging in volunteering with local organizations. Your faith community. Those can be some of the most protective health impacts of stress. And then know your numbers. Making sure you know what your blood pressure is. Know what your blood sugar is.
放点音乐，这样你就可以投入其中，从而思考你自己。但另一件事是，你可以帮助其他人，参与当地组织的志愿服务。你的信仰社区。这些可能是对抗压力的最强有力的健康保护影响。然后了解你的指标。确保你知道你的血压是多少。知道你的血糖是多少。
Making sure that you're thinking about healthy diets in a way that's productive. Those are kinds of things you can do. And all of us really should know what triggers us, what gives us the most stress, and do everything you can to avoid those at all costs. There are a couple of things that Georgia said that I think are really important. One of the ways that we work with people who are experiencing psychological distress is that we ask them to intentionally do things that they enjoy, that do pleasurable things. I can remember when I was working clinically so many times I would ask people that question, like, what is it that you really love to do?
确保你以富有成效的方式思考健康的饮食。这些是你可以做的事情。我们所有人都应该真正了解是什么触发了我们，是什么给我们带来了最大的压力，并尽一切努力不惜一切代价避免这些。乔治说的一些事情我认为非常重要。我们帮助经历心理困扰的人的方法之一是，我们要求他们有意地做他们喜欢的事情，做令人愉快的事情。我记得当我做临床工作时，我有很多次会问人们这个问题，比如，你真正喜欢做的是什么？
And then I ask, the next question is, what was the last time you did it? And often it would sometimes be not months, but sometimes. years. And so people don't do a lot of the things that they get a lot of pleasure from. And as a result, they're really cutting off a really important way of coping and handling stress. The other thing that I wanted to point out is that one of the things we know from the research is that the older we get, the better we're able to handle stress. And in fact, there's a really clear, linear relationship that the older we get, the less stress that we have. And so that really suggests that one of the things that happens is that the more experience that we have, the better
然后我问下一个问题，上一次你做这件事是什么时候。通常有时不是几个月，而是几年。因此，人们不做很多能给他们带来很多快乐的事情。结果，他们实际上切断了一种应对和处理压力的非常重要的方式。我想指出的另一件事是，我们从研究中知道的事情之一是，我们越老，我们处理压力的能力就越好。事实上，有一个非常清晰的线性关系，我们越老，我们感到的压力就越少。因此，这确实表明发生的事情之一是，我们拥有的经验越多，我们就越好
we're able to handle stress in our lives. And so, you know, talking about social support again, if we, if you are a younger person, but for any of us, reaching out to people who can help us problem-solve can be a very effective way of helping to manage our stress. All good points. Now, the stressors we've been talking about are also affecting the public health and the health care workforce. What does this sustain stress do to the people who are delivering care? What's the impact on communities and what can we do to help those people who are trying to help the rest of us? You know, I think it's important that we remember the caretakers because far too often the people that are supposed to be taking care of us, which, of course, in my world,
我们能够处理生活中的压力。所以，你知道，再次谈到社会支持，如果我们，如果你是一个年轻人，但对于我们任何人来说，向能帮我们解决问题的人求助，可以成为帮助管理压力的非常有效的方法。都是好观点。现在，我们一直在谈论的压力源也在影响公共卫生和医疗保健劳动力。这种持续的压力对提供护理的人有什么影响？对社区有什么影响，我们能做些什么来帮助那些试图帮助我们其他人的人？你知道，我认为记住照顾者很重要，因为往往本应照顾我们的人，当然，在我的世界里，
are the public health people. They're as stressed. They're the ones getting up every day, and I've seen that far too often. You know, I'm doing hurricane Katrina. People forget that you had public health people responding to that terrible flood, and yet almost all of them had lost everything as well. And so they were trying to deal with that tragedy. During a hurricane we had in southern Maryland, I remember that just the health care providers
是公共卫生人员。他们同样压力山大。他们是每天醒来的人，我太常见到这种情况了。你知道，我在卡特里娜飓风期间。人们忘记了有公共卫生人员在应对那场可怕的洪水，然而他们几乎所有人都失去了所有东西。所以他们试图应对这场悲剧。在马里兰州南部的一次飓风中，我记得不仅仅是医疗保健提供者
but also the politicians, the people that had to show the, you know, the stern face and get in front of television cameras and tell us that things are going to be okay. They were under enormous stress. So we need to make sure that we're taking care of them as well because they're under enormous stress. And Dr. Evans, for the mental health practitioners. Well, I think that there are a lot of things that contribute to stress. One of them is that especially from people who work in the mental health field, that area
还有政客们，那些不得不表现出严肃的面孔、站在电视摄像机前告诉我们事情会好起来的人。他们承受着巨大的压力。所以我们需要确保我们也在照顾他们，因为他们承受着巨大的压力。埃文斯博士，对于心理健康从业者来说呢？嗯，我认为有很多因素导致了压力。其中之一是，特别是对于在心理健康领域工作的人来说，该领域
of health care is often underfunded. It's been chronically underfunded. And that means that there are often lower wages. But there are also, the working conditions are much harder. When I was Commissioner of Behavioral Health in Philadelphia, I remember we were funding some of the community mental health providers. And we were just giving them small grants to do things like to be able to paint the waiting room. I was doing this in the morning.
医疗保健往往资金不足。它一直长期资金不足。这意味着通常有较低的工资。但也有，工作条件要困难得多。当我是费城行为健康专员时，我记得我们正在资助一些社区心理健康提供者。我们只是给他们小额赠款来做一些事情，比如能够粉刷候诊室。我早上在做这个。
Then later in the afternoon, I went over University of Pennsylvania. for an appointment, and I walk into this gleaning building and there's modern equipment. And that striking disparity between how we support and fund people who work in the mental health field and how we fund the rest of health care is just glaring. And that shows up not only in our ability to provide care, but it also shows up in the impact
然后在下午晚些时候，我去了宾夕法尼亚大学赴约，我走进这座闪闪发光的建筑，里面有现代化的设备。我们如何支持和资助在心理健康领域工作的人与我们如何资助其他医疗保健之间那种惊人的差距是显而易见的。这不仅表现在我们提供护理的能力上，而且也表现在对试图提供该护理的人的影响上。
on the people who are trying to provide that care. So I really think we have to think about and understand public policy and make sure that public policy aligns with supporting all of the people in health care. And then I also think that we can do some things to make sure that people who choose work in these areas don't have disproportionate economic stress. We need to make sure that people can pay off their student loans because most people have to get loans to do this work. And so it really is a comprehensive approach of making sure that we're funding, but making sure that not only the systems that people work in, but we're funding and making sure that the people are getting the kind of economic support that they need in order to do the work. And Dr. Benjamin, just to close up here, what about the long-term prognosis? I mean, we're dealing with, as we've said, you know, a lot of stressors or a lot of things happening in the world that are making things difficult for all of us. Is this the new normal or is there some light at the end of the tunnel?
所以真的，我认为我们必须思考和理解公共政策，并确保公共政策与支持医疗保健领域的所有人保持一致。然后我也认为我们可以做一些事情，以确保选择在这些领域工作的人不会承受不成比例的经济压力。我们需要确保人们能够偿还他们的学生贷款，因为大多数人必须贷款才能做这项工作。因此，这确实是一种全面的方法，既要确保我们提供资金，又要确保不仅人们工作的系统，而且我们正在提供资金并确保人们获得他们做工作所需的经济支持。本杰明博士，就在这里收尾，长期的预后如何？我的意思是，我们正在应对，正如我们所说的那样，你知道，很多压力源或世界上发生了很多让所有人事情变得困难的事情。这是新常态，还是隧道尽头有一些光亮？
Well, I think that things are certainly going to be different. And in many ways, the amount of stress, the amount of activity going on, the fast moving on society is the new normal. But we can adapt. You know, we've learned to adapt as a society for many of these things. And so I think the things we should do is not say that these things that are an assault on our mental health or our physical health, need to go on challenge. So what can we do? We can make sure that as an employer,
嗯，我认为事情肯定会发生变化。在许多方面，压力的数量，正在进行的活动的数量，社会的高速发展就是新常态。但我们可以适应。你知道，作为一个社会，我们已经学会了适应其中的许多事情。所以我认为我们应该做的事情不是说这些对我们的心理健康或身体健康的攻击，需要受到挑战。那么我们能做什么呢？我们可以确保作为雇主，
we're providing people with the tools that they need, the crew time, as I mentioned earlier, giving them some time to rest, helping them think about their day. If you as an individual with your family plan to have stress-free days, build, construct your day in a way that reduces your stress, how you get to work, when you get to work, how you engage your family, getting your family some me time, both individually and as a group, are things that you can do to try to de-stress both the environment and the type of way we engage people. And then, you know, what I've noticed is that we have more and more people who, frankly, are having conflict. And when you start looking at how that conflict occurred, far too often is because there's,
我们为人们提供他们需要的工具，正如我前面提到的船员时间，给他们一些时间休息，帮助他们思考他们的一天。如果你作为一个个人和你的家庭计划有无压力的日子，构建，以一种减少你的压力的方式构建你的一天，你如何去上班，你什么时候去上班，你如何让你的家人参与进来，让你的家人有一些属于自己的时间，无论是单独的还是作为一个团队，都是你可以做的事情，试图消除环境和我们让人们参与的方式的压力。然后，你知道，我注意到的是，我们越来越多的人坦率地说有冲突。当你开始研究这种冲突是如何发生的时，往往是因为有，
emailing one another. You know, they're in the office, and yet they're still having a social media connection instead of getting up, going to someone's office, and all the issues in the office have become even controversial and full of conflict. And so we need to figure out ways to de-stress the workplace as well. Dr. Evans, anything that you see on the horizon, any hope for us to get out from under all of this? Well, I think the larger stressors that were experiencing, probably not. I think Georgia's made a great comment that, you know, we've been under chronic stress for the last several decades. And if you look at our stress in America survey, for example, stress levels in the United States have not varied a lot, if anything,
互相发电子邮件。你知道，他们在办公室里，然而他们仍然在使用社交媒体联系，而不是站起来去某人的办公室，办公室里的所有问题甚至都变得充满争议和冲突。所以我们需要想方设法消除工作场所的压力。埃文斯博士，你看到地平线上的任何东西吗，有什么希望让我们摆脱这一切吗？嗯，我认为我们正在经历的更大的压力源，可能不会。我认为乔治发表了一个很好的评论，你知道，我们在过去几十年里一直处于慢性压力之下。如果你看看我们的美国压力调查，例如，美国的压力水平并没有太大变化，如果有什么变化的话，
they've gone up over the last several years. So it's not like we have a period where we are experiencing intense stress and then that calms down and we have a break. It has been constant. And if you look at both the political environment, you look at the economic environment, you look at the social environment, those stressors have been constant. So the issue isn't how do we lean more into those break periods? We just don't have those break periods. So we have to, as people, have ways of coping and strategizing around how we deal with stress. So that means that we, first of all, we need to understand it.
在过去几年里它们一直在上升。所以这并不是说我们有一个经历强烈压力然后平静下来并休息一段时期的时期。它一直是恒定的。如果你看看政治环境，看看经济环境，看看社会环境，那些压力源一直是恒定的。所以问题不在于我们如何更多地倾斜到那些休息期。我们根本没有那些休息期。因此，作为人，我们必须有应对和制定战略的方法，围绕我们如何处理压力。这意味着我们首先需要理解它。
We need to understand that it can come from lots of different ways. we need to understand that it is insidious, that often we're not aware that we are under stressed, but our family members know, our co-workers know, and one of the things we can do is to give them permission to give us that feedback so that we're getting that feedback. And it's important for us to know our own signals for when we are experiencing stress. For me, for example, if I start to become cynical, I know that I'm stressed because I'm typically not a cynical person. But when I started to hear myself do that, that is a sign. And so I know I need to step back. But it's also, you know, not only having a literacy around what causes our stress, but it's having
我们需要明白它可以通过很多不同的方式到来。我们需要明白它是隐蔽的，通常我们没有意识到我们处于压力之下，但我们的家庭成员知道，我们的同事知道，我们能做的事情之一就是给他们允许给我们这种反馈，以便我们得到这种反馈。了解我们自己在经历压力时的自身信号是很重要的。例如，对我来说，如果我开始变得愤世嫉俗，我知道我感到了压力，因为我通常不是一个愤世嫉俗的人。但当我开始听到自己这样做时，这是一个信号。所以我知道我需要退后一步。但它也是，你知道，不仅要对导致我们压力的原因有一定的素养，而且要有
literacy around what reduces our stress. We gave some great examples. But understanding that stress is manageable, but there are things that we have to actively do in order to manage the stress in our lives. And that when we do that, it actually works. when we are taking better physical care of ourselves, that actually helps us to manage stress, when we are increasing our connections to people in our lives, that actually helps. When we are doing things to rethink and to not catastrophize,
对减少压力的原因有素养。我们给了一些很好的例子。但要明白压力是可控的，但有些事情我们必须积极去做，以便管理我们生活中的压力。当我们这样做时，它实际上是起作用的。当我们更好地照顾自己的身体时，这实际上有助于我们管理压力，当我们加强与生活中人们的联系时，这实际上是有帮助的。当我们做一些事情来重新思考而不是灾难化时，
that really helps us with our stress. And so doing those things consistently can help us manage through these very difficult and challenging times that we're experiencing. And, you know, I like to add, there's some things you should not do, right? Tobacco utilization, vaping, drugs, alcohol, those are not things that we ought to do to try to de-stress. Yoga, me time, extra sleep, more exercise, good things.
这确实对我们的压力有帮助。因此，持续做这些事情可以帮助我们度过我们正在经历的这些非常困难和充满挑战的时期。而且，你知道，我想补充一点，有些事情你不应该做，对吧？使用烟草、电子烟、毒品、酒精，这些不是我们为了减压而应该做的事情。瑜伽、个人时间、更多的睡眠、更多的锻炼，都是好事情。
And maybe chocolate ice cream, but in moderation. You know, one of the things that I think is really important is to be able to do things that you enjoy and not feel guilty. One of the things that we've learned in giving days off for our staff to take mental health breaks is that many of them would use those days to try to catch up. And so I think we have to have this culture where we understand that taking a day off is not being lazy. Taking a day off is actually helping you to sharpen your act so you can do your work more efficiently. And I suspect that if we have that problem within the APA, that other organizations have the same problem, that it is not, that you don't have to feel guilty to take time off, to take care of yourself. That is just a good habit that can help all of us. Excellent point.
也许还有巧克力冰淇淋，但要适量。你知道，我认为非常重要的事情之一是能够做你喜欢的事情而不会感到内疚。我们在给员工放假以进行心理健康休息时学到的事情之一是，他们中的许多人会利用这些日子来试图赶上工作。所以我想我们必须有这样一种文化，即我们明白请假并不意味着懒惰。请假实际上是在帮助你磨练你的行为，这样你就可以更有效地完成工作。我怀疑如果我们在APA内部有这个问题，其他组织也会有同样的问题，即它不是，你不必为请假照顾自己而感到内疚。这只是一个可以帮助我们所有人的好习惯。极好的观点。
Thank you so much. Both of you, Dr. Arthur Evans, Dr. George's Benjamin. Thank you for joining me today. Thank you, Kim. Thank you, Jim. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology. or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review.
非常感谢。你们两个，阿瑟·埃文斯博士，乔治·本杰明博士。谢谢你们今天加入我。谢谢你，金。谢谢你，吉姆。你可以在我们的网站speakingof psychology.上找到“心理学对话”以前的节目，或者在苹果、Spotify、YouTube或你获取播客的任何地方。如果你喜欢你所听到的，请订阅并给我们留下评论。
If you have comments or ideas for future episodes, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你对未来的节目有评论或想法，你可以给我们发电子邮件至speaking of psychology at APA.org。心理学对话由莉·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。谢谢收听。我是美国心理学协会的金·米尔斯。本期节目暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。